looks like Maksim Chmerkovskiy has hung
up his dancing with the stars shoes for
good the 35 year old is saying he will
quote definitely not return to the show
that made him famous max left after
season 18 when he took home the
Mirrorball with olympic ice skater Meryl
Davis and he's telling glamour the time
was right he said quote I think the
change of guard is necessary like a
plant that in order to improve growth
you have to pull branches it's the same
thing every now and again everything
needs to be refreshed will you promise
to stay by Derek Hough was a surprise
return in season 20 but according to max
he's really on his way out now max said
quote I think this might be one of the
last times we see Derek we've moved on
and the show is still where it is I hope
the show stays for another 10 years and
we'll come celebrate it when we're a lot
older are you guys surprised to hear
that Max is done with Dancing with the
Stars for good or do you think he'll
eventually be back like you know Derek
style send me your thoughts on twitter
by
you